[Music]
okay uh good morning to everybody a good
afternoon depending where you are uh
so um
oh okay oh so i assume that you hear me
well uh in this case
uh good
so first of all uh i'm very happy to be
here and to be the part of this
conference
i really
think that
julia community
is something that is worth
uh
being in
inside
um okay so uh just not to
take too much time
off
i will share my screen
okay
i assume that you see my screen uh wait
tomorrow yeah
you can hear me great oh okay i'm very
happy to hear it
um i of course just to remind you from
the organizational perspective
there is also this pigeon hall
where i also have this opened on the
other screen
and if you would have any questions you
can both
post them uh in the comment section of
the youtube video
or
in this piece of home i would try to
answer
each question uh whenever it's possible
if some questions would be longer i will
just uh
just tell you to wait with it but i will
try to answer
everything that i will be able to
uh hello from groogray
so
first of all what we want to achieve
today uh
and who i am
so uh i am physician um
during the last year of specialization
nuclear medicine so basically uh it's
like radiology um and i'm also the
programmer and the senior data scientist
in
polish national
science institute
um today i am not
planning to show you the state of the
art of the
medical imaging
uh or medical segmentation medical
imaging but i will try to show you what
can be done
um and what can be done in julia because
what is i suppose quite logical i
consider julia as the very good
place to uh
very good environment for medical image
segmentation why and exactly how it
looks like
i will
get in a moment so
first
i assume
that most of you do not have any
knowledge
from
either medicine
either the
or gpo programming i saw some knowledge
from julia
if something would not be clear please
tell me and basically the strength the
whole strength of the workshops as far
as i understand this is that you can
interact with me this that you can ask
me questions and that i can clarify
anything uh that is problematic on the
fly so do not hesitate
i suppose this is the most important
difference between workshops and the
video that we recorded that you can see
it later
so now
if you have any questions please ask me
so
first i will introduce you to medical
imaging data format so
how we how one needs to work with it
what are the challenges
uh some loading of the data and simple
processing using one in or simple atk
and python call
then
i will show you how to visualize the
data using my package made by 3d
then we will
show some way of
dealing with multi-dimensional data
using
julia language
using
gpu with the julia language which is
also very important how the hdf
5 data
dataset basically is working and how the
sdf5.gl
how many volumes and labels to load oh
this is a good question
and this is what i want oh wait
basically
it's enough to get one
one volume and one label is enough yes
from any size that you get and we will
work on one example at the beginning yes
uh at the very end i will show you also
some um neural network uh how it is
um
wait a minute uh
and in the end i will show you uh how to
get the neural network in this case of
course you would need more examples for
it but we will not do it live because it
just takes hours so it would be uh
impossible uh is there any way to get a
good area the julian environment uh
frankly
okay
uh frankly uh we will
um
i'm sorry
uh frankly it is very simple yes you
just load cuda and you are ready if you
have the gpu card with the
um
leave you have on indie
um
in the environment basically in the
computer that you are running if you
have the nvidia gpu card the
cuda.gl team has done perfect job and
basically it just works yes so when you
have this uh jl package you do not need
any docker yes for example this is one
important thing when i'm using for
example python uh for
data science i
uh yes you can do it on the cloud yes
you can do it on the cloud julia
computing has such cloud and uh
yeah
julia computing is sharing it but this
may be another cloud yes it may be for
example on the google or anywhere else
basically yes you can do any task yes
only the paths would be different
and this should be the ct scans yes you
should have ct scan and some label and
basically anything could be good okay so
it can be
[Music]
annoying which data test should we
download from your drive if you want to
follow you at home
uh basically uh
task nine if you want this
display oh i see that it's changed about
this data set i will get back in the
moment if you do not have nvidia gpu
card you also can follow most of this
you would not be able to follow uh from
the uh sometime but i will tell you at
the beginning the viewer should work
without the gpu card basically no at
least without dedicated gpu card
um
okay so uh
basically you can either have the city
org data set or the spleen data set so
task nine from the medical degree both
would be good and i will uh mentioned
about them both
um
so and
um
yeah
so this the link to the data is in the
description of the youtube video yes so
if you do not have yet the data please
uh start loading it because it will take
some time
okay
so if there would be any other questions
let me know i will try to answer them on
the fly
okay
so about this it's enough first of all
what are the alternatives uh because
there are far more established
frameworks for dominican imaging
segmentation for example demoni i one
that i'm using
a lot basically
it's implemented a lot of the state of
the art
and have a lot a lot of tools really itc
very old
very long history uh it's over 20 years
old but
it's also its strength so it has a lot
of algorithms the ldk that i know the
least inner eye
that is quite automated and so on
um
but
if there are so many
already very well established very good
frameworks for medical imaging uh why i
decided to spend the last year and the
half on developing some tools in order
to enable uh working in julia
first of all
this is because of julia itself
obviously
so
julia offers a couple of things that i'm
extremely interested in
and are extremely useful so
the most important frankly is
interoperability
interoperability is because of this
property of julia that it is not
uh it solves this two language problem
yes so for example if you can in pi in
python
it's very hard to cooperate between
different packages very frequently yes
if something is not built with the
thought of the pa supporting the pie
dodge it's very likely that it would not
work with python yes
in case of julia it's not the case if
something is was built it's very likely
that it will work with pretty much
anything yes
because pretty much anything is working
with julia arrays yes
more or less at least
the other thing is gpu yes about this i
will get in the moment other thing is
package manager basically in case of the
python i cannot
work basically without the docker yes
because the environments can be very
complicated
in
case
in case of the
uh julia this is really really well done
and uh
we do not need to
oh sorry
screen is not showing it's very good
that you're telling me there was nothing
here but okay now you see it
uh there was yes i was just talking um
no there was nothing interesting on the
screen just this one but good that you
are merging this thank you very much
and the other thing is that um
we have a lot of unexplored
possibilities in julia
so julia has tons and tons of packages
that are
having implementations of um
a lot of mathematical uh modeling
concepts that are
very hard to achieve in python yes
so
just getting it all together if you have
something if you want
to perform some classical medical magic
if you want to you have
to perform medical imaging yes using
some
already established known algorithm
usually would get be better off
in python yes because it's already
implemented into big extent however
in case of the julia if you want to do
something new if you want to if you
think about some new algorithm uh
it's basically at least in my opinion
far easier to achieve in case of julia
uh because it's easier to
cover it yes to to get some new idea
from idea to execution and to
use
huge amount of tools that are already
implemented
so this is the basic idea why julia
and why i why i did it yes so i did uh
oh i will get to this in the moment so
first of all
uh why this gpu programming is so
important now when you
have medical imaging yes this is some
medical imaging data yes
so
what you see here is the brain obviously
but
from computer perspective this is a huge
r yes and me huge is
really really huge so it can be billions
of points yes because for example it can
be uh 200 1024 by 1024 by for example
1000 yes so it can easily achieve
billion uh points by
for one image and there may be multiple
images per patient
yes
in most cases it's not as big as i
described but it can be huge
when you have huge amount of data we
can a lot get a lot from parallelization
so um
them
with such huge amount of points to
analyze
um we can divide the algorithm to work
on each point or in each group of points
separately
so the more we fret we have the more
work we can parallelize and um
in practice there is really little limit
in this
so this data is really good for
parallelization for a lot of
types of algorithms that's why gpu where
we have a lot of
threats they have some limitations of
course but gpu generally can have
thousands of cars yes cpu usually have 8
16 32 yes
very very top end let's say gpu you know
the normal gpus can have thousands of
course and um
this is um
game changer in case of this type of
data yes so when you are working with
such huge
data arrays um
this will uh
change
the speed of execution 100 fold
even more yes sometimes i had seen some
algorithms that were 1000 times faster
than gpu
um okay so this is about gpu
why hdf5 about this very shortly this is
just a way um how to organize the data
uh this was created for the high
performance computing uh you can think
about this as the
extras files yes so we have groups like
folders and data sets that are just
multi-dimensional arrays yes so when you
think about typical data
database yes it's usually tables
in this case data sets can be
multi-dimensional which is critical for
for this case because
it has
the support for the
support for the three-dimensional or
four-dimensional
arrays and has metadata that is also
very important and to which i am getting
now
uh so
um
first of all uh as you heard um i
suppose many times in order to do
anything in data science i you need to
understand your data
and what does this data represent
so uh
but
date medical data has a lot of
variability and a lot of formals that it
can be
um
set in yes it can be in daikon can be
nifty can be in drawing can be an mhi
sometimes it can be hdf5 so it's
important to load all of it yes it's
important to parcel it and pre-process
all of it in
the way that would be useful for you
um
okay
okay so i suppose uh to be honest i do
not understand
uh what you are reading here i do not
know the uh cyrillic um or russian i
don't know which one never mind
but
if you have any questions you can post
so
now when we are looking for example at
this images this is the classical
radiological image uh
what we can see here we can see
where what are the physical properties
of the bodies that are here yes so
whether this is balloon yes like here
filled with water and empty one
we can see whether the
um rtg race can get through
or not yes this is quite simple so when
you shine the rtg race on it you can
just describe it whether it can go
through or not and this is just the map
that shows it so when you look for
example at this square yes when you look
see this uh
this rectangle sorry
you can decide you can say that in this
place a lot of x-rays get from in this
place not much so we have some map of
physical properties
of this
um
glass yes the same is with the body yes
so this is a map of some physical
properties different study will mean
different properties
but the idea is still the same
what is also important you can quantify
this property yes so this radiolucency
or basically how easy it is to get for
the x-ray to get through in case of the
x-rays or ct scan
and different tissues different
substances will have different numbers
associated
uh because of it
we can easily imagine this
as the multidimensional array yes so
each point will be usually not always
usually some floating point number or
integer
that
explains some
value of this particular property in
given spot okay so in given spot we have
given radiolucency in given spot it is
so easy to get through with
some types of radiation or not
um okay this one is already no yes in
case of the ct scan what is also
important
we can uh
view 3d images yes we can do 3d images
but in truth
uh those 3d images are because we have a
lot of 2d images yes
i will uh
um get deeper into it in a moment uh and
we'll get deeper particular and to see
discounts so i will concentrate on this
for a moment yes so uh in ct scans
basically what we do we slice the
patient yes so we make this uh
slice of the patient then go
millimeter or two millimeters depending
on the case uh in one side get the other
slice get the others let's get the other
sides yes you will see it in the moment
um and then we process it and then we
will tell in which point
how um
well
in which point uh how easy it is for the
arrays to get through basically yes and
here we have the image yes so we can see
that it is far uh harder to get through
the bone yes than the ice for example
and this is what we can see
uh in the end we have the array yes uh
and
we know how to work with the r basically
yes because if you are programming i'm
sure that you had
been using a lot of arrays um and to
some extent this is always the same but
there are some differences yes so apart
from this that
each voxel
so voxel is this
three-dimensional pixel yes apart from
this that each box is representing some
uh physical phenomenon is the quantified
physical phenomenon
and the other thing is
um
that it is also somewhat in physical
space what i mean by physical space yes
i mean that when the person patient is
lying yes
we have somewhere right somewhere left
and it makes uh it's important whether
it's right left superior inferior
anterior posterior yes so in which
direction the patient is lying where do
we start it yes so uh
where do we start counting for example
millimeters from the foot so from the
head or from somewhere else
uh so where we exactly yeah so i would
like to know later yes for example when
i see the ri whether
the heart is i don't know
50 centimeters from the head or 40
centimeters from the head yes
we need to be able to retrieve such data
because of it we need to store this
metadata so one of the metadata is like
this yes so we need the origin so where
we started and the directions
without this the
basically we cannot interpret it fully
the other thing that is even more
crucial from the practical perspective
is spacing
uh spacing uh
we will see it
in practice
when we start
the proper workshop
the spacing is
the fact that the voxels
does not have uniform dimensions what do
i mean
that when we have
the array we generally consider each
element of the array as the same yes
in case of the medical imaging it's not
this the case it's not always the case
at least
so we can the vox cells has some
dimensions in millimeters yes so it can
be high and thin
or it can be more quadratic yes
okay one the uh custom formats hdf5
dicom are needed uh why do not use
ordinary file systems and folders
basically hdf5 is just something uh not
so commonly done it's something that i
have implemented here and proven to be
fast usually data in clinical setting is
used in daikon yes dycom is some
standardization of the data
um
data storage um
and in nearly all hospitals or maybe
even all hospitals uh the data is in
daikon yes the other uh the other
ways so nifty uh hdf5 uh
and others usually are for scientific
purposes
why they are not just ordinary file
systems
because uh we need this metadata
i just mentioned the most important from
a critical perspective metadata yes so
what is the origin what is the direction
what is spacing um but there are more
yes for example it is written uh what is
the patient's
[Music]
gender yes what is the
um series that we have what were the
exact properties of the current that was
used in order to generate the image
what is the
what is the device exactly because it
can matter that can be thousands of
things written in metadata yes so
basically this array is this
three-dimensional array that we will
work with and it will be always the same
and it could be written in some in some
file
but this in order to standardize this
metadata we need daikon for example
okay
but very good question
uh okay i assume it's answered if it's
not please let me know uh if you still
know want something more
um okay so but just getting one more
time to this in case of the spacing yes
we
have this uh
optical disturb distortions yes it's
good to check whether there are some
artifacts or not yes and some
information about the artifacts is also
important from the perspective of the
um
from the metadata
yeah very good okay so this is the
example you would see it on my viewer
basically um
how it does not look yes if you imagine
the lungs that you have on your own
it's not so compact yes
uh
so it's wrong metadata but i will not
delve into it you will see it later yes
and this is one more time yes you have
some ri coordinates it's like this point
and then you need to be able to say
where physically it is yes so how many
millimeters from other points in order
to know it you need to know the
direction the origin and the spacing yes
so you need to know um
that for example moving three voxels
uh left right
means that you moved three millimeters
yes or five millimeters or ten
millimeters yes it depends on the
spacing okay
okay so now uh just two things to show
that uh
about
the things that
i implemented
uh so this is for example some mean
execution time yes in case of the my
viewer and
some classical viewers so this is quite
normal both on windows and ubuntu and
this is
the matrix um in the logarithmic scale
yes so basically um this is not yet
completely published but you will
also see today um the metrics um
in julia when implemented by coda.jl uh
order of magnitude faster than
the best implemented cpu and similar to
the state-of-the-art gpu
on the
monae
okay so we'll get into you can see the
code okay so first of all
maybe i will increase the size can you
see it well do you want it to get larger
[Music]
yes is it good or you want it
to make it larger smaller
okay
basically i'm not on discord uh it's
perfect for you okay i'm not on discord
okay good okay thank you for feedback
uh
i had not logged into the discord now uh
i am just now on the pigeonhole
so if you want uh get come here
you want larger okay so i will make it
larger
okay
so i suppose it would should be done
well now
so first of all uh we are in my uh
repository
uh at the moment i'll just
okay
so the link is also
in the
uh
the link is also in the uh
description of the youtube video i will
send it in a moment uh just for
everybody to be at the same spot and in
the source directory we have this uh
julia notebook
yes
you know test no never mind
and here we have uh the notebook that
we'll work on yes so i'm just sharing
the
link one more time
for everybody to
to have it
okay
okay
and uh
and we are here okay so uh i asked you
uh
some of if you had read uh earlier the
description i asked to download some
data
that
uh
basically any data with the ct scans and
some labels uh would be good um and you
also could
load these libraries yes we are using a
lot of libraries so
this could take some time
yeah so first of all we just execute
this
and
and get
the libraries loaded into our
environment
i already have in this environment
everything loaded loaded but of course
if you do not have it
um
i will
okay it's good very good
so
and the second thing that we can already
start uh is that we need to establish
some paths
first establish some path to the hdf5
data set that we'll already create now
yes so just provide the path um
so modify the path that i had added here
um and just provide the path to some
folder that exists okay so the folder
needs to exist and then we can keep the
name so it will keep
as consistent but it does not matter
so i will give you a moment to
load the libraries and
establish some path yes in the meantime
do you have any questions
enlarge even okay
okay
okay so i'll give you two minutes
for this
load library and
okay
some new question
have you also considered to calculate
exposure time to andre for cancer
treatment with your program is it
possible
angle for cancer oh you mean
radiotherapy
basically
there is nothing that would work against
yes the most important thing about this
framework it's not closed yes
i just gave some visual visualization
data
some um
helpers helper functions to save the
data and load it
but uh
frankly you can do it yes because um
this is not like typical uh python
frameworks yes uh this is created with
the interoperability in mind and it was
very easy to establish basically in
julia
you can visualize my data
visualize your data using my
visualizer i will get into in the moment
how to do it exactly we'll spend some
time with it
you can
load the data in the arrays and do
basically anything that you want uh
you can save them in the hdf5 format or
not if you want you can
save it in some other format do not use
this part of the framework yes you do
not need to use the metrics at all yes
you
can use only the
visualizer yes or you can use the
metrics yes to check for example the
difference between the gold standard
established by the radiotherapist
and
the output of the algorithm yes so you
can use any part of the program um
per se yes so there is nothing that
would prevent um
prevent uh incorporating and
developing some algorithms in the
radiotherapy for um using my tools
basically and then another tools
okay and there are some
where is exactly located the toolbox one
more time
the notebook is in this uh
uh
jacob maturayas madpipe 3d tutorial in
the source yes
and it's called julia notebook test yes
i will get one more time the link to it
uh and i will share the link one more
time on the
um
in the comments to the youtube
okay
so
okay i will try to answer this
okay i edited my uh
but generally i answered your question
in your question yes so i i did edit it
edited it okay
so is it possible to run this uh an
online rep yes yes
uh basically i use normal
of the
of the julia to be honest uh it's worked
a bit better in rebel than in python in
in the jupiter notebook uh when i'm
working day to day i always do not use
jupyter notebooks this is
just easier to show
during the workshops what is happening
and where exactly we are but usually i
do not use it i just execute the parts
of the code
in the terminal
each rep
should be i should be okay
okay uh so uh just know are you there
any problems
at this point yes do you have any
problems for a moment
can i assist you
okay i assume that there are no problems
if there are do not hesitate to tell me
so i will think how to solve them
so
i assume that we already have the uh the
libraries loaded um
i added this coda looks kind of true
this is some technicality basically uh
in order to
have high performance code it should be
false uh but in very specific points i
just needed it uh
to reduce uh to get the last reduction
let's say maybe not
to get a single number from the uh it
was very useful to get it at the very
end in my particular case it was not
leading to some problems with
performance
because it was just a final operation
um okay here
so
this is important point because in case
you would work with it on your own uh
this may lead to a lot of headaches um
when you are opening the hdr5 database
yes
uh
this is the
this is the vanilla let's say um
hdf5 this this part let's say it's not
related to my framework at all so when
you open this you need to supply the
argument
uh whether it's write or
read and write yes when you would supply
it's like this so it's right you are
creating new database
so you will overwrite the old one so if
you already had something
uh there it would be deleted this is
important so if you would do not want to
um delay what is already there you you
get air plus for example yes or arm does
but if you do not have yet anything you
just paste a w as right okay
i will
destroy the old data database
intentionally because i just want to
start from scratch with you
then later we are
getting some number of the patient
this is just a conversion that i created
so we have the number from the
data set basically
um
these are two
hyper parameters that i will elaborate a
bit more later
so how big is the area from which to
collect data and what should be the
numbers of clusters
um and this is also some technicality i
will tell you later a bit what is it
uh what is important also
as i mentioned at the very beginning but
i will tell it one more time is i'm not
showing the state of the art yes i'm not
the
idea being the purpose behind the code
that i implemented here in this workshop
is not to get the highest performance is
to show exactly how it works so i'm
using very simple things and um
showing how to use my tools to some
extent and other tools and how they play
together yes uh this is not to get the
best um results so if you would not get
very good results this is quite probable
that you would not get because it will
be variable between person to person
between data to data between patient to
patient yes
in this particular implementation
do not
don't be afraid of it yes you can have a
very bad results and maybe i would have
also yes because this is quite random um
to some extent at least uh with this
particular implementation i will show
more stable implementation at the very
end but uh this is relatively slow to
train
so
um
there was some problem technical
problems with the description to the
youtube video uh
i do not know uh
who has
what type of data is mostly represented
but
there can be the spin data set yes from
the medical degation or ctr data set
both of them would be okay yes however
in case you have this spring data set uh
just to make it easier yes you've got
this data directory so the folder with
the spline
and then you use those two lines in
order to get train labels and train
images uh directories yes
this
part is just uh
collecting the paths yes so there is no
magic here that we are just collecting
the paths the full paths
of the files that we will work on in a
moment if you have city org data set um
you
pass it you can pass it like that yes
you need to push all labels into labels
folder all volumes into volumes folder
okay so you need to do it manually so
you uh are getting the
all labels yes so labels one labels two
labels three and so on in the labels
folder all volumes so volume one volume
two volume three and so on in the
volumes folder yes and get the path to
the folder that contains the labels in
volume folder okay
okay is it clear for now do you follow
so here we are just collecting the paths
to the data yes
uh the and basically it's just important
that you would have here
you can even if you want you can even
just copy and paste it yes so if you get
the train labels yes like this and you
will get here the uh
as the path
and thus you have to
get the patient number one yes and you
have just a single path here yes
it will be okay
so you just need to collect get me here
yes some path to that
to the volume yes
and today sorry here is label yes here
is images so you just need to get
one path to the volume one path to the
uh to the label yes and it's enough
okay
okay let's go on
then you zip um the
puffs yes so you
create
basically the zipping looks like that
that you are getting from entries from
one list yes and second list you have
the
a
b c yes
[Music]
the first list
okay it's windows
uh you have the
the
f in the second list and it will create
the list of tuples
and that will have the first element
from the first
array and first element from the second
array is the first 11 from the first eye
second element from the second array and
so on
a spleen dataset url is wrong
okay and
i will get it one more time wait a
moment
that one
okay you can get here
i'm just showing it one more time
and here you can click the get data and
task nine would be the screen yes
now you can download but the city arc is
far bigger yeah so
um city org data set is bigger so it's
might be hard to get it now yes but
um okay
so
uh and then we are just choosing some
pair yeah so this
toppo is just single pair of the
um
label path and image graph yes and
you could target spacing yeah so um you
will see in a moment how does it work
exactly
but
in case of the target spacing we can
change the spacing to something else yes
so we have some original spacing and we
can
change this spacing okay
oh and i did not post the link to the
ctrl data set if you want okay so city
or data set
um
okay so and here you have if you want
i'm also posting the link to the
city arc
dataset
if you have some problems with the
medical degato both are okay yes
in case of the city org we have multiple
labels
so we just need to modify
the entries so we will just keep the
entry one
yes
uh because the entry one is the lever in
this case
in case of the split we all in case of
the
medicare medical degradation splint data
set we all already have the splints so
as you can see below it's not needed yes
and we'll just pass the data to some
other data format for convenience and
what is important and
i'm working to change it but for now um
you should rather work with the 32-bit
representation for my viewer yeah so my
viewer
just understands for now at least
it may change uh the 32 bits yes so it
may be float 32 it may be the infinity
to you in 32 but it needs to be 32-bit
it's related to how the data is passed
uh to the opengl
okay there's some new question
what does changing the spacing mean in
this country okay very good question
yeah we will see it in the moment in
soon at least in the practice
uh i will have make some visual visual
visualization
okay so oh i do not
execute this here so it should execute
slightly fast so one more time we are
just loading the paths and using some
path um to load the data into the uh
arrays yes so the label r and image and
you can see it's already locked in my
case
now
now we manage the data using the hdr5
and this is not required but it's useful
basically um so here what i'm doing i'm
creating the group as the group you can
think about group as the folder in case
of the hdf5
and
i create the group with the
name of the patient group name yes i uh
that we established earlier
uh
default value is one yes if you do not
change anything
then we have
we save the mask before visualization
into the data set and
what is here yes uh
this is just a name yes image and label
set so this is how it will be called
this data set inside
and this is the type
yes so later when the data would be
loaded from the
data set these types are important yes
because this would be parsed in
different colors yes and this could be
passed in different colors yeah so the
city have different way to visualize and
the labels have different way of
visualizing this uh all of the labels
are described in uh indeemed uh pipe yes
because just for those that
did not have it we there are three tools
that i implemented you can use
all of them or just one of them as you
wish
and one is for visualization met i 3d
other is for matrix yes and others is
mudpipe connecting
dose and hdfi data space
and we also write the attribute group
attribute spacing yes you can add
another that you want here so this is
not
the spacing is required but if you need
something else because your data
has some special metadata for example
you can add anything that you want
writing this group attribute and then
retrieve it
okay
so here uh
we are getting to uh defining how
visualization should look like yes so in
the med eye 3d
uh meta 3d uh
describes how each mask how each array
should be visualized yes
so
um
in case of the oh at the moment
not here sorry
in case of my viewer
all of the data is stacked on
uh
on its own
okay
i just will
show something
okay pheromone this one was suffice uh
so basically
when we have the data yes let's imagine
this and the 2d data for a moment yes
they are in the layers basically
so all of the data so this one would
could be ct this could be layer for the
manual modification this could be the
layer for the label yes so they are over
one over the other each is also
described as the texture
just because how the opengl uh defines
it yes so the opengl is the library um
for the visualization basically it's
used for example for games so it's uh
hyper it's
have relatively high performance
and
this data is in the layers each layer
can have different properties how it is
displayed here so for example ct scans
would be white and black and have a very
specific clamping we'll see more about
this
labels would have also other colors and
will
look differently and so on yes and pat
for example would look also different
uh okay
so
and here we can define some things about
uh how we want to visualize it yes
so um as you see here i just
get a
toe
texture specification
so the manual modification and algo
algorithm visualization yes
but we all already had loaded here
the um
ct scan and labels yes so we have four
allies total
what's important when we just put the ct
scans and bull labels um this will be
saved
and then loaded the texture
specification automatically
you can override this by uh supplying
your own texture specification yes so
you can put your own texture
specification get some colors a single
color if you want just a single color
and that will have wiring intensity on
multiple colors
then you supply color set
uh if you supply colors that basically
the continuous mask should be true
otherwise not so critical if you want
the mass to be editable yes so
to have the ability to modify it using
the mouse basically you need to point is
editable to true
it's good to supply min and max value it
could be inferred but
if you provided
the visualizer or will get proper
bottom and
upper
threshold here so intensity would look
better basically
but
it was should still work without it
what's also important
we have i created
utility function get some color yes
you can override this using some
manually chosen colors get some color
just get some next color from the list i
had found somewhere in the internet the
list of the contrasting colors and
this function just
takes next color from the list yeah so
it's automated
if you do not want to think about this
um however just one thing to know when
you are using this function
and the
uh you the colors may be different from
execution to execution here so if it's
important for you to have exactly the
same colors each time
you are using it it's important to
override it i will show you in a moment
how to operate
and this is the main function yes so
this is the function that takes patient
group names yes
and uh
all right
now
i missed it sorry
[Music]
here
i did not execute this
okay
now it should be good
yeah
also
i left it intentionally
in order to increase performance
you can increase number of available us
yes and this is the error that will be
posted
the warning at least and that will be
printed if you did not enable the
multi-threading in julia
it can be done for example in the
settings on the vs code
but it will work still without it okay
so now if you executed this line
you should have something like this
okay
so this is a viewer
with the loaded ct scan yes
and the labels in case of the city arc
you would have deliver in case of the
spleen data set you will have the spleen
okay
so now just to know uh
are there any problems
that everybody got here yes
maybe i will make a short break just to
end the body to catch up
and then we'll go on
now describe how to
uh use
the
the visualizer and the annotator
okay in the meantime if you have any
question uh
let me know i will look into the chat
and into the comments yes and i will try
to answer anything but uh let's make a
some break
and we'll go on okay
okay so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay and
i told you uh just to be sure so let's
get back at
1705 okay
so at 1705
let's get back
okay so in one
in 10 minutes yes 9 minutes
okay but of course oh i see some new
question
okay what syntax error
you can show me what is syntax error so
maybe we'll uh get this and everybody
else has a break
but if you have this syntax error
tell me how it looks and i will try to
to help you
shader creation error
oh so this is related to some
some opengl problem
you are using this um on the
laptop on the pc pc computer
and do you have some
gpu do you have some gpu maybe this is
the first question
because layout syntax error
is probably not julia related and not
related to this one
but in order to be sure you can also try
the different patient yes so you loaded
some puffs yes
and one mug
okay
to be honest i did not tested this on
the
mac computers because i do not have any
access to this um
what you are showing me here is the
opengl problem
okay
opengl
so
hmm
okay so i would not like to i do not
know anything about
max is basically how mac os
is working um but i see that the opengl
uh can be installed in the macos yes so
um
i would tell you
in case uh basically
from the tech stack yes it's based on
the opendl
and uh vl
every year so
this is uh this contains the definitions
in theory opengl should work on all of
the platforms yes
but
as you say as you
mentioned it does not need to be true as
far as i see
so
and as i googled it it seems that opengl
can be installed
on the mac os
so i suppose it could
we could try it i hope it would help
okay one more thing that i had
heard
and seen also is that in case of the
linux sometimes um it gives the error
say that there is the error uh that
the application hangs
but
you can ignore it yes this just brings
the error that doesn't mean anything and
it works
okay i hope it will help yes so
and thank you for uh for mentioning
the problem
okay
okay i will
get one more time d
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay so i'm back
so i hope that
there are no problems now
i will delve into how to use the
the visualization
um
so first of all yes you scroll using
your scroll uh in the mouse so you get
from up down up down
uh this is medical data yes so we and 3d
medical data yes as i told you
in case of the ct scan
those
what we see now is also transverse scans
so those slices through the organism
are the has the highest resolution
basically because they are the original
ones let's say
but
we can also see a
patient from the site
and from the front yes
uh
this is uh used by
pressing space and
one would be sagittarius so from the
side space 2 would be from the front
space 3 would be transverse now
um what is also important when you press
f
yes it's scrolling fast as you see now
when you press s it's scrolling slowly
yes so one more time f for fast
scrolling
and space one
space to
space three yes the commands executes
when you
release the keys yes so you keep the
space
one two three and when you release this
should be visible okay
what's also important as i explained to
you a moment ago um
the
visualization is layered here so we have
different layers on it
uh one layer is as you can see ct scan
the other layer is labor we also have
two other layers yes for the
output of the algorithm and for the
annotations
with the annotations
this is relatively simple
you just click and drag and you see
the interaction yes
so this and you can see it's saved it
can be seen also on
um
other images like here
um so this is how the annotations works
yes you just click and drag
you can also increase the size of the
annotator by clicking tap and plus yes
or decrease by pressing tab and minus
even to very small
tap and plus and minus all of this is
described in the repository of the
medici
this is important because
when we will
later
describe try to analyze the
[Music]
segmentation is of the lever in case we
have now or in the spin in other case
we'll use the data
about the boxes that are close to the
annotations that we created okay
so uh but about this in a moment more
yes now
so this is these are the layers we can
show and hide the layers also yes so we
can
pressing ctrl and number we are uh
hiding the layers here so control and
number has the left so now i
hidden everywhere
by pressing shift and player you show
so shift 1 in this case will show the
ct scan shift 2
will show also deliver shift she will
she'll also
understand
uh yeah here and she sorry shif3 was the
algorith output and shift 4 is the
layer of the annotation okay
uh
what's important is that you press the
shift
to see something and press the control
to stop seeing something okay
these are the most important uh there
are also others but um let's not delve
too much detail for now if we would have
some time i will give you more about how
to describe uh it's in modi
if the visualization does not work to
you uh
soon we'll get to more algorithmic
approach that you would not need
visualization for um and i will help you
later in order to remedy this problem
still if you have any problems please
write it on
okay so i will
just get this on the other screen for a
moment
uh so we are here yes we displayed
already the data we see
what
was the case yes so we see that the gold
standard label is like this what we want
to achieve we want to achieve that our
algorithm would have exactly the same
[Music]
properties yes would have exactly the
same position
the output of our algorithm would
give us the label that is exactly the
same as
the gold standard yes so this is the
gold standard created by um some
physician
manually and we want to um
repeat it by our algorithm
uh but before we do it uh just a bit
more uh playing with the display yes so
uh if you do not like the display that
was done by the automatic colors
you can change this so you can see here
for example i changed the color of the
manual modification and label set
getting manually rgb values yes
yeah so now i execute this
and we see the colors are different
what's important also the labels well
sorry
the annotations were removed because i
did not save them yes but now i can
recreate
okay no questions for a moment good
and now another very important
very important part that i want to show
you about this spacing will play a bit
with the spacing um does everybody
follow yes anybody needs help
anybody needs help
okay
if you want let me know uh but now uh
some of you ask what about the spacing
yes so now we have the spacing one one
one what does it mean it means that we
assume
uh that
each voxel has one unit of
length depth and height yes so it's a is
a volumetric basic okay so
and this is how we pass the data so we
change the data in order for it to be
true
um okay i see some question
okay
numpy not available
it's strange but okay wait a moment
there is
either way
so you can try
um
[Music]
i will find just a snippet to
share with you
oh here it is
okay
in case
it did not work
where is this
okay
uh here
in case you have problems with the
simple ipk loading you can load it
like this yes so you can also load by
monae
so it looks basically the same you
supplied the first and second
first argument is the
uh path to the label second path uh
second part is the path to the um labor
first of the image second to the left
sorry
uh
and it will also return the
tupu with which where the first argument
would be the ri of the
uh image as the second
would be the array of the label
okay and i will just i do not see
the way to
to answer this question for a moment so
i will just
modify
your question
so you can use
this function is loaded by my from image
and
label box
yes because in order to install the
numpy
you would need to
change this a bit
for a moment and i will
just help you with it
[Music]
it does not want to work with me
okay
okay well you can do it like this and
fast
[Applause]
okay
okay okay
uh so i will just save it
okay
so now
uh as you get to the top yes you can
load the matpi 3d uh from the source yes
i uploaded the numpy
to the conda
environment
if you would rebuild it it should work
okay
so i hope it will help you
um
[Music]
you can also try this monae
basically i'm working to
to get rid of the python dependencies
but this is work in progress
but if you have still some problems you
can just
reload the
the
dependency yes the data and i hope it
will go now well
okay
uh where we are we are into spacing okay
so here
i hope that
others does not have any problems
okay
so
we have this situation that we see the
image like this this looks normal yes if
you imagine your hips for example have
more or less such shape yes
and so on
now let's
let's change it yes so for example let's
say that the third dimension so the
height of the voxel is three units
so it's not one unit it's three units
um
so now how does it what does it change
yes first of all when you look at this
it looks exactly the same but
it looks the same because we did not
change the
x and y direction yes x and y is the
same
but here you see that the image looks
compressed yes
it looks like the person would be
pressed from top and bottom
this because um
the viewer this cell thinks
that each voxel from top to bottom has
three units yes
and
uh because of it it needs to squeeze it
yeah
if it would really be three newtons it
would look normally but it's not it's
really one by one by one
but we have broken it intentionally now
um to change it yes
[Music]
okay and now let's
change it
some other value yes
okay and one more time yes and now
i change this to 0.5 yes and we see that
it's elongated yes we are not so high we
are not so
thin let's say and you look at the hips
yes for example we do not have such a
long hip relativities to the rest of the
body yeah so
this is what the spacing means basically
that
if we get the spacing trunk we get the
distances wrong and we get a lot of
information lost okay
so
um
okay
so let's get back up before we forget
yes let's get back to the original
spacing case one by one by one
uh this is how
it looks like okay and now uh if you
have city org data set so you see
deliver
mark now using your mouse yes
the
somewhere in deliver if you have
the spleen
data set mark it in the screen okay
so now it's important do not to forget
to mark some annotations inside it's
also important not to have anything
outside yes
um
if you have just reload
it will be the simplest phone for a
moment but we need some spots
in delivery
okay
so now uh
from those spots what we would do yes uh
on the basis uh maybe what the what is
the hypothesis yes we have the
hypothesis um that
the
neighborhood of the each of the boxes
that we marked as the lever so each of
these points that i uh pointed here
um
is representative for whole of the liver
yes so that each neighborhood of these
points
is
similar to neighborhood of each voxel in
the liver
so we are collecting the local
information of the
boxes around any given point and we will
use it for our algorithm algorithm to
guess where is delivered in the whole
image okay
so this is the hypothesis this is the
idea behind it very simple idea a very
simple algorithm
will give us some results that we can
see and understand
so
first of all in order to get the
information from around yes we need to
know exactly where we are
um the very nice thing about julia is
that it supports cartesian
indexing yes so it supports these x y z
coordinates uh
we can use it in a lot of different
fantastic ways um one of the thing is
that we can just get cartesian indexes
of the
some area yes and just filter those that
we are interested in so we get cartesian
index of the area around the point and
we filter only those that are in the
distance that we specified yes this
distance specified is the hyper
parameter here so you can we defined it
at the very beginning
um
by z parameters remember uh but it can
be different yes you can look further
away or closer
it depends on you you can
play with it if you prefer uh but here
we are just choosing the cartesian um
cartesian indexes yes that are in the
uh distance from the center box yes
here
we are filtering from the array
that we uh annotated all of the indexes
that has the values bigger than zero
yeah so all of the indexes that we
annotated basically because it started
we started from all zeros so everything
that is not zero uh was is our
annotation and here is basically the
same as earlier so we just get some
patch around yes and patch around patch
because we need to get
all of the points properly
here is important so we get sample and
uh
mean and standard deviation so around
each of the boxes we get this
neighborhood yes
uh maybe i will
get the idea here now yes so iran when
we have this data yes this is a grid of
boxes
uh we decide we know the delivery is
somewhere here yes we chosen some voxel
here
then we the which
we had we know the cartesian coordinates
of it
we
had defined some amount of cartesian
coordinates around
and in this green
circle yes we have some set of
voxels from this set of voxels
yes this is just array of numbers we get
the mean yes and the standard deviation
or variance and then square rooted it
but the important idea is that we get
the patch that is the representation of
the data
that is here okay
and then the question is no okay
[Music]
um then
and this is what is happening in this
get sample mean and standard deviation
as i said this is just the example to
get from the very basic some algorithm
that works without and
let's say magic and without any player
for
now um
so
we already have some functions that can
define it
so in order to do this we need to get
the access to the arrays that we have oh
i did not execute this
okay so we need to get the errors yes
uh in order to get the array from the
data that we defined yes we defined the
data
here yes so when we load it we define
the object mainscroll date yes
uh and this
object contains all of the references to
the arise with the data
uh what's also important from the
practical perspective
when we are looking at this all of the
data so all of the arrays are living in
the julia apart from this one that you
see yes so
when we scroll we each time scroll the
new data yes um just the data about
given slice just one slice is living in
the opengl context in the gpu yes so it
does not
get a lot of gpu memory uh it should
work on basically any gpu even
integrated um
and
because the data is in the julia we can
access this and modify this at the fly
this is one of the critical
parts why i created this visualizer yes
because in most cases when you have some
uh tool to look at medical imaging you
need to send the data whole data
frequently save this as a file and just
load this as a file yes you cannot
modify it at the fly in most cases there
are some exceptions
um there is napari that was created and
this was a very good tool but in many
cases is very hard to achieve
and now it's also in slicer notebooks
it's also possible
uh here is very convenient at least in
my opinion
uh so
uh we also um
so now what we are doing the most
important things is happening here
so we get this coordinates and we create
uh patch statistics from it yes here
so we get all of the points all of the
points so
yes here here here here here every we
get every point we get coordinates
around and we get um
some statistics about each part yes and
then we map it
um to get distributions how we get
distributions we use the
julia package about the
distributions package and we just fit a
normal distribution okay now we are
doing all on the cpu so
it can take some time
uh
but it's all it's quite intentional
because it's very simple to see yes uh
and it's also
useful to
understand what is happening here so we
are not doing so much work yes we are
just getting about each point around in
this neighborhood yes it seems like
simple however um
as you patched any point you did not
patch one point you push you get a lot
of points yes around this about nine
points around uh so it's hundreds of
points and getting all of the
neighborhoods all of the standard
deviations all of the means
generally starts to be a bit problematic
okay it's not a huge problem yet but it
starts to be a problematic that's why
when we are executing this on the cpu uh
like now um it can take yes two minutes
something like this we'll get
to this
yes so it took one minute on my cpu um
without any parallelization without an
optimization
really relatively simple task but we
have a lot of data yes that's why it is
um it can be slow yes
um and in this case as i said it's
international
so
uh how to deal with this problem that it
is not as fast as would like to there
are two things one thing is to use
different
hardware and different hardware
techniques the other thing is
algorithmic
so let's start from the algorithmic
perspective yes so
we have
one more time just to
have everybody on the same page we have
created around these points on the basis
of the data on these points the gaussian
distributions yes those gaussian
distributions uh gives us the
probability whether the given
argument
is
similar to the lever or not yes
so around each point we create a
different gaussian probability
distribution but each gaussian
probability distributions
is um defined in order to
uh show us what is the probability that
this point uh belongs to the lever okay
so
but we have
hundreds of them for now uh we want to
reduce it how we can reduce it uh this
is just some idea that i have uh
uh it's also showing that you can use
any package an idea that you have and
play with it
i created the some simple clustering yes
so
at the moment
here
okay so i created some simple clustering
that basically uh
from all of the probability
distributions that are present yes
um compares them using kl
callback libra divergence and checks
where are in this space let's say
uh defined by the callback liberal
distance so it's basically some bonus
number
um where are each
probability distribution it says whether
they are similar or dissimilar
and
the clustering
just covers the similar distributions in
the same clusters
yes
so where they are similar they are in
the same clusters and next i'm choosing
single probability distribution from
each cluster
to represent it the idea is that if a
lot of gaussian distributions are
similar
they hold the same data and they are
redundant yes so i get um
get rid of this redundancy by first
getting only those uh gaussian
distributions that are the most
important uh for the task effect okay so
they are the most different from each
other
okay
and then we are choosing those
distributions i've chosen nine district
different distributions that are most
dissimilar
now
as
we explained a moment ago of
just getting the
data of the neighborhood
around each point that we have chosen
was already a bit demanding task but
what we need to do now
what we need to do now is uh
quite harder basically
[Music]
okay
what we need to do now is we need to get
uh
voxel by voxel yes point by point and
there there are millions of them
and
execute the gaussian distribution
yes
sample it
and a certain sample generally put the
argument so each voxel and some of its
neighborhood
into each gaussian distribution and take
the maximum
from all of these functions yes so we
get each voxel neighborhood around each
voxel
we get the standard and mean
standard deviation and mean we put this
data into each of the gaussian
distributions
yes and
we get the
maximum from all of those executions
what is critically important this is
millions upon millions of operations
relatively simple but a lot of them
if you would do it without any
parallelization
it could take
something like half an hour easy
maybe even more
but we can do that this parallelization
and um how to achieve this first of all
here i am defining some uh additional
functions just to get the constants of
the gaussian distributions
because um
here
as we see the this is the um formula for
the gaussian multivariate gaussian
distribution
and you can see
that uh
a lot doesn't depend on x yes so all of
this this does not depend on x can be
pre-computed yes so like the
normalization constant uh like the
inverse of the
um covariance matrix yes
can be it can be computed earlier
so we just needs to calculate x and we
get x and calculate the probability
from this formula
okay
so uh how to speed it up the best way
basically well i suppose at least uh is
to
uh execute this in the gpu using this
massively parallel um
framework that i described earlier
first of all
this is for convenience this is how i
like to do it you there are a lot of
different ideas
this is macro for the iteration what is
micro if you are not um if you get from
some different
um language the macro can be
[Music]
a bit foreign let's say but macro is
just a way of the very smart very
advanced code generation tool
yes so when we would execute this macro
the
expression
would be executed here and would get
access to all of the context here what
is happening here it's relatively simple
so i will enjoy it in a moment also but
uh the important idea is that we need to
know where we are
and
establish our position from this point
yes so uh in case of the
here in case of the uh cuda
yes we have thousands of threads
as we explained earlier
so we need to get the idea where we are
yeah so where each fret is
so it needs to know uh in which
point of the array it is present so in
order to do this we use this thread id
x block id x
block d
dimension uh x y and z yes
when we know where we are we can
load the data from around in order to
get this part statistics from each box
as we as i explained earlier
now
when we
already have this data from this area
um
we can will iterate
in the given area here so rr is this
range in which we are iterating and we
also need to check whether we are not
um delving outside of the array itself
and this will iterate around each boxer
yes
and now what is happening here here we
are defining the kernel yes the kernel
for those that
does not have an experience of gpu
programming is the program
that is executed in the um in the gpu
yes
this is using the cudado gl uh
absolutely fantastic package uh
basically without the timbersart i would
wouldn't be able to
perform any of it
and
what is happening here yes we are just
getting mean
what is mean we are summing up all of
the values from this range yes so we are
doing it around here so we are executing
this multiple times in the given
neighborhood
and then we are getting the variance
and
the um by getting the square root of
variance we get the
standard deviation
and then we save the output into the
correct point of the array one more time
in order to know where we are we use the
thread idx block idx block dmx and so on
uh
there are very good
videos uh created
in the julia community for the team
besides and but not only um that are
explained exactly how it works and
they are extremely well done
what is also important
we need to
define how many threads per block
we need to
execute this is some technicality but
basically
the threads in the gpu are organized in
the blocks
and works
and all of
these and all of this needs to be
managed basically during the runtime so
we need to decide how many threads and
how many blocks
we need to execute
in
practice in production let's say uh one
which should also use the occupancy api
that
gives us the best possible
threads and blocks
configuration but
today for simplicity i omitted it yes
and then we execute the
uh the card
what happens during this execution of
the kernel
uh
first of all we need to have the data in
correct spot
so
if you are from the
background of
the dynamic languages
okay
did you face any uncallers access or
race condition problems
uh
in yeah basically the race conditions
are the
thing that happens very frequently when
programming in any parallel code um so
yes of course in case of the anchorless
access yes in
this access is not much collects yes
this is not very well um
optimized from this perspective is
because this is a very simple code
i didn't want to get to too much details
basically
what i had
seen is
very good is
when you are
getting two-dimensional
kernels yes and this is three dimensions
but when you get is two dimension and uh
when each thread block is getting one
layer by one layer yes so it gets or
just down down down down down um also
it's very nice if you can represent the
if the data is binary for example you
can represent the data in the
in the binary format yes for example
encode the integers um
in the data in the bit representation of
the integers it's getting easier than to
get memorable lessons yes so um
and just for uh others that does not um
remember maybe about memorical lessons
this is huge topic about memory care
lessons and one of the most important to
get the most of the gpu basically for
the gpu one of the most important thing
is when you load the data
and how you load the data
because those threads that has the gpu
are not working um
on its own on their own yes they are
working in groups uh these groups are
vaps yes works of in case of the nvidia
gpu at the 32
in case of the amd gpu it's supposed
128 and they are called the front but i
can i don't know i don't like
uh but in case of the nvidia gpu it's 30
to work
and they in order to get fast data
loading they should get data that is
close to each other in physical memory
space yes because when we have the
three-dimensional data it's still a list
yes it's a list
that uh has defined where each dimension
starts when each layer let's say edge
column intro starts and when when it
ends
uh by some metadata uh
but it's still a line of numbers
basically yes so in order for the warps
um you know for the gpu to work the best
we need to uh get the data from uh the
spots that are nearby yes so optimally
the each work so each 32 frets
should have the data that is next to
each other so 32 consecutive places in
the memory okay
uh this is very important from this
optimization perspective i did not delve
into this here i did not try it even in
this spot in
implementation of the matrix uh so in
this let's say more production code it
is implemented to maximize the score
lessons whenever i'm able to and of
course
but i am sure that it still can be done
better than i did i um i'm learning this
but still i there is a lot of land
a lot of other things that i don't know
yet
um okay i hope that answered your
question if
there is still something more let me
know um
okay
so now we have this
um wait a moment i did not executed this
so
no i did not execute this one also
[Applause]
i forgot to get a lot okay
okay then i will execute this then when
i will execute this
and then i will escape this
so
wait a moment apply ghost current
notified
it is defined
frankly that's why i prefer basically
the command uh executing this in command
line
it usually works better but it will work
also so uh what is
the um the important thing yes
we are doing here huge amount of work
yes orders of magnitude harder that we
did
when we were just
finding the
distributions yes
it then took us one minute yes and here
the huge work that we needed
took only 19 seconds on my gpu at least
and it's not optimized code yes as you
mentioned already so it's not optimized
code and it's already
very fast yes
if we would do it on the cpu it would
take as i suppose half an hour if it
would not be optimized we still can
optimize it and so on but um it would be
very slow
uh
okay so this is the idea and now what we
what we done we uh we executed yes we
executed the kernel so we has
established
how much each voxel is similar to the
lever or spin depending on which data
set you are using
and now
we have um
yes and we executed the kernel in what
is important
in order to execute the kernel we need
to copy the data onto the gpu yeah this
is also big topic on in the gpu
programming that
we do not um
we cannot execute any algorithm on the
gpu before getting the data onto the gpu
yes
and the copying the data onto the gpu is
happening like this so you just wrap it
the normal array in the qra this is one
of the ideas or you can get the copy too
this is other way
but
if you but in order to copy to of course
you have already some qra
uh
present already okay
uh okay did one gpu allowed you to store
all the image data into global memory
yes in this particular case yes
the data um
it is couple hundred
megabytes uh for the image i chose a not
too big image basically
and
this algorithm is quite lightweight yes
so this algorithm does not pose big
problems with this
if
for example for training 3d neural
networks it will be problematic yes we
would need to
create some mini batches but this
algorithm does not require us a lot of
free memory so we've there should be no
problems particularly with the spring
dataset yes the spin data set
i chosen this and i posted this because
it
has very small images that will not
overrun your memory
uh
but yeah
in some cases of course you need to
part the data into the smaller pieces
but this algorithm was chosen to
to get very low memory footprint
basically
uh
reduce operation where we are
basically uh in the metrics i am using
uh free stage reduction okay now this is
also important topic so i will get to
this um
so in case of the gpu yes when we are
looking at the gpu um
we have those thousands and thousands of
threads yes
uh what is there are two things that are
problematic that we usually do not think
about when we are
programming on the the cpu yes uh the
first thing that
is data moving this is usually the very
big deal that's why these data
collections that we
had described earlier uh was mentioned
and the other thing that is very
important is communication between frets
yes so imagine that you have a thousand
people and you need to communicate all
of them at once yes and to coordinate
all of them it's hard task
and that's why the reductions tasks on
the gpu are relatively hard yes
so what is the reduction test the
reduction task is that we have
information from all of the spots and we
want to get some
[Music]
single or reduced output from it yes so
the simplest reduction is the sum yeah
so when is sum we get all of the
elements and we just add them
uh we have mean and there are thousands
and thousands of possible reductions yes
limitless possibilities in order to do
this in them with the biggest um with
the best performance we do
several step reduction yes so first of
all we do reduction in the warp then you
do reduction in
of all works yes in the thread block and
then you do reduction of the whole of
the
gpu and if you have multiple to four gpu
between gpus
so this is
in case of the state of the artist in
matrix it's not it's done like that so
this matrix that i will show you later
uh is the multi-stage process here
uh
yes it's it could be done in the could
not reduce uh also
is very effective way to do it um and in
this case as you mentioned it should be
done later in order to get more uh
better performance yes so
uh
i do not see where i did it but i i'm
sure that i did it somewhere so uh what
this uh what uh marushiro panzoli i
i'm sorry for mispronunciating this uh
of course this is a very valid comment
this is how it should be done
in this case of such a simple reduction
this would be a better idea
in order to get to maximize the
performance
okay thank you very much
um okay so
um
now let's go on yes and here we already
have this data we need to copy this data
one more time uh to the cpu because
um our visualizer our tool for
visualization is getting the data from
the cpu
um
we are dividing by the maximum element
just for standardization to see better
and refresh
in order to
get the data from the
last layer
here
and here
uh we see this very nice we can
okay ah
to be honest i like this image this is
what we have
get yes as a result you should see
something similar yes whatever uh
basically whatever you get the spin or
lever it should look similar because
frankly as you see both spleen and liver
has
very similar
um properties very similar local
properties
so you get
these points of high probability
uh getting all around the spleen and
liver so spleen is here liver is here
this is vertebral column for example
if you have some pro questions about the
anatomy of course you can also ask
and
so
here is the
leave her one more time and here are the
spots of ha that our algorithm decides
that there is a high probability that
this is a liver yes what's important our
algorithm also told that it's high
probability that this
was yes
that it's wrong promise
um
so what we can do next yes
we see yes uh when we would
yes
shift 2 is getting the mask back yes
so when we get back the uh the mask we
see that there are two kinds of problems
first problem is the spleen
and second problem is that
we just got some points in the liver but
most of the liver is still not
recognized as the lever yeah so
we a lot of voxers is like here like
here like here here here and so on are
not recognized as delivered by the order
algorithm and this is a problem
um but
we know one thing that if
there is a point that has from each side
um high probability of the liver it's
probably a liver yes
so if you are here for example from all
sides there is a high probability of
liver so probably this is all delivered
so we can use the data about the
neighborhood about the output of our
algorithm and to perform
the refinement of our algorithm
so our organization can get the idea
that we have
the lever also here and here and here
and here by looking that all of a lot of
boxes around has a high probability how
to do it the classical algorithm for
this is the relaxation labeling
so um
just to get it uh
one more time this is to show you a lot
of different tools and this is
i suppose the best tool um available in
the maybe um
the bus is too big but
it's i'm huge fan of the parallel
stencil basically so the panel stands is
the library
that enables you to
get an extensive computation as far as i
know this was created for destiny
computations for
a modeling of the glaciers or things
like that but it works extremely well in
this medical imaging domain uh so what
is the science operation just to for
everybody to know this is something that
we already did yes we have some point
and we
get
the all the operation is based on the
data from around yes so we get the data
up down left right
in some code in some neighborhood
basically of this point and we execute
the function on each point
based on the information of the
neighborhood
how it looks like like this yes so you
have the
you define this parallel tensile
parallel indices is the simplest one to
work with
you define like this in order to be sure
that uh our indices are not getting out
of the array um and
you choose the arrays yes you choose the
points that you are interested in
okay so you are we i'm choosing here as
the minus one in x direction
yes
plus and uh plus one in x direction yes
my plus one in y direction minus one in
the y direction so all points around and
i get some mean yes
so when i get this mean there uh this is
the seven point numerous tenses
basically um
so i'm not get not looking in the object
directions
and on the basis of this i can define
these
relax labels function so this relax
label function
will look around we'll check what is the
probability the mean probability around
we'll check whether this probability
around
is above some threshold yeah some rate
um
and if this
is above this threshold it will decide
that this given point
changes the label to the point to the
thing that is um typical for the
neighborhood
so one more time you are getting in
single point we are looking at the
neighborhood if there is a high
probability that this is the lever or
this is a spin in the neighborhood we
are changing this point to being a lever
yes
if there is a lot of
and the other way around is also working
so it's important if you have a lot of
noise
this will help to reduce the noise
because noise generally will be isolated
so in case of the noise um it will
decide that there is a liver for example
somewhere in the brain yes and but there
would be there wouldn't be much boxes
around that will also tell that this is
a lever yes so we are using one more
time the um
the data from the local neighborhood
um and here we are defining the rate and
the steps here so how many times we want
to execute this relaxation labeling and
what is this rate so uh basically from
um what threshold will decide that this
information from the neighborhood is
significant
uh more or less
and we can execute this yes so when we
execute this
zero six seconds yes this is a mavic of
the parallel stance
um
[Music]
so this is already very well optimized
library
and you see
that
our algorithm is our
yeah so our algorithm already knows
enlarge the image parts yes so in case
of the spin also yes because there was a
lot of foxes that decided that here
there are some points also in the um
[Music]
in the stomach yes
in the gastric mucosa
basically
but uh
we are getting a better job still there
are a lot of points that are not
uh marked as deliver that should
yes so what we can do
in this particular case the situation is
simple we execute it one more time
yes
and it's getting a bit better yes you
can see that now in these parts nearly
all of the lever is
is granted yes
however we do not know in order to get
an algorithm to work we need also to
calculate how well we are going
um and how well we are going we need to
have some number so we need a metric yes
uh basically when you are looking for
how
the algorith
how well it's performing now you have
either the metric or the loss function
yes the loss function is usually
defined when we want to minimize the
loss function yes so in the
context of the optimization the metric
does not need to be easy to optimize i
define the metrics that and i'm working
on
to getting some new loss functions
but for now i have the metrics
uh and here we are not performing an
optimization in this particular okay so
um this um does not matter so much
uh however in order to get a metric we
need to have data prepared yes there are
a lot of different metrics but most of
the metrics um
are
based on the fact that we are that
algorithm should be sure about the
result yes so we are checking each voxel
yes one by one
and
on the basis of each voxel it should be
either liver or not liberal yes or it
should be some labor or other labor
but now we have different situation now
we have floats floating point numbers
here so our algorithm decides that
basically in
some places there is high probability in
some places we have low probability so
we need to binarize it
so this is also very simple thing uh we
can do the kernel or para stencils or
you will we could even um
it would be better even
to use normal
array
code arrays working to uh to map it but
we need to threshold it so when we have
the value above some threshold yes in
this case i
arbitrarily given the point half uh we
would decide that this is truly a lever
if it's below it's not yes so we
threshold the data
it should look like
uh
to look the same basically
uh because as we just threshold it is so
it does not change much from the viewing
perspective
uh we can now also the save the data and
close it maybe not for now
so in this this is also important from
the practical perspective when you would
already have some data that you want to
save yes in this case i decided to save
a manual modification
layer but you can save any other mask
output of the algorithm and so on to the
hdf5 just to persist it yes
okay
so
now we will think about what to do
better
and but let's first make a short break
if you have any questions ask me i am
here um
yeah so let's make a
break till 18
8. okay so let's make the break 18 8
and uh
and then we let's get back
to the ideas to show what we can do of a
run uh i will look into the chat and
into the
pigeon
and
if you have any questions and the
problems uh please let me know
thank you
and see you in a moment
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
java
foreign
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay so let's get back
to this
so now
um
[Music]
okay so if you have any more questions
please ask me uh
i will try to address it make this open
thank you very much yes i see this uh
just after someone after time
okay
so
uh now let's go on with the what can be
done better yes so
this is uh
as you seen this algorithm was done from
the very basics without any
magic let's say
and
um there's a lot a lot of things that we
can do better but the one of the
simplest things that we can do better is
just to
tweak the parameters yes
i suppose that whether you started from
the lever or from the spin your image
basically can be similar to it yes in
some cases there will be also a lot of
um artifacts in other places yes so
as i said this is not
something that was created to work
extremely well yes
um
but
we can get better yes a bit at least
we can
do the hyper parameter tunic yes so the
hyperparameter tuning is also very well
established in julia
uh so here i collected most of the
things
that you we did earlier just without
copying it
[Music]
here
because i got too fast sorry we did not
yet perform the
metrics yes yes yes yes
okay so let's get back here because i
forgot that i did not yet showing you
the
performance matrix
this is also very important idea uh
so here we are what we are doing now
next thing is next up
here we already had threshold so now we
need to
define the matrix and display the
metrics
uh
we can
just get a lot of different metrics this
is defined in the uh package
documentation what metrics exactly can
be called
uh here i decided to get uh two metrics
in configuration uh struct yes so uh
michael nobis distance
and dice score yes so these two dice is
very classical there are a lot of uh
works now that as the dice is not so
good but
still it's the most widely used metric
um that
is around basically and now what is
important you will see
displayed
on the image as dice and maharnam is
distance at the top left the price sorry
the values of it what is important the
values will be different yes because
these are different scores in case of
the spleen basically your performance
will be far worse why
because when you are executing around
the spleen
all of deliver would be the error yes
when you are executing from the lever
all of the spleen is there since pin is
far smaller
[Music]
as i said it can look very bad it's do
not be afraid of it uh so in case of the
spin data set but the spin that they
said said is far smaller so uh that's
why it's was also positive
and this also works
so
now just just to get back uh to the idea
about the matrix and how these different
metrics
what they measure
[Music]
okay so um what uh what about
what is so special about the medical
imaging and that it needs some
specialized metrics because it doesn't
so first of all let's imagine the uh
common problem that we have the lungs
yes and in the lungs we are looking from
the tumors yes
what is important from the numerical
perspective
is that the tumors are relatively small
or can be at least relatively small
relative to the whole volume okay
in case
it is very frequently the case that what
we are looking for
is very small
that's why
when we are
defining the metric
uh
that tells us how well our our algorithm
performed we need to take it into
consideration so we need to take it into
considerations that there is a huge
misrepresentation yes so when we are
just um
so for example if you would like just to
increase the
maximum squared errors here so sorry
mean square error yes mse or any other
classical metrics
we would be um the algorithm usually
would converge just
to very simple thing that all voxels are
background
because this would be very simple if
only
let's say the one percent for example of
the voxels are true
tumors
and
uh
and the algorithm will just tell that
everything is the background
yeah so there is no tumor at all it will
get 90 yes eight or something like 99
but very basically extremely
good accuracy yes
very small error
although it would be completely rubbish
yes it would be completely useless but
it still would get a very good metric
that's why we need to take into account
this
misrepresentation of different labels
and one of the ways how to get
this into account is this dice metric
uh this is very classical
but still very useful magic
however when you think about dice metric
what it does it basically takes into
account um how many voxels are
really
recognized yes in the structures to how
many is not recognized yes so let's say
that this is our algorithm
output and this is uh the true case yes
so uh the dice score will not look at
all around basically it will mostly look
at
what is
well recognized yes so that our output
algorithm
founded this part
well
but it did not found this part although
it should
and this found this part although it
shouldn't yes so we have this um true
positive part
yes
false negative
and false positive
so this is basically how the dice score
looks like
um and joha carter a lot of others
get on the base the same idea
what is
important they do not take into account
the distance
so when we are looking at the distance
so for example uh from the perspective
of the dysc whether the
the mislabeled voxel is so distant or so
close is the same
in order to take into account the
distance we need some distance matrix
yes like this mahalanobis distance
so when we are looking back
on the image yes so mahalo's distance is
not completely symmetric so it's not
normalized at least not in this case to
uh the range between zero and one um but
here you can
basically get the idea that
if you would do it a lot of time yes and
compare between different cases michael
novi's distance will give additional
penalty to all voxels that are distant
from the true image yeah so the spleen
would be heavily penalized because it's
far away
and the boxes that are just next to like
here for example will be not penalized
so much yes
they would be recognized as a small
error and this will be recognized as
bigger
from the dice metric
this and this error so this voxel here
that is not in the level and this voxel
here that is on deliver is equally
invalid yes
and this is a big problem of the
dyescope um
with that
that's because um a lot of researchers
are uh thinking now about getting the
uh the metrics
in order to look into
it uh okay
so
uh going on with this
okay so going over this we also have
this hyper parameter tuning yes and how
to perform this hyper parameter tuning
in case of the julia it's really simple
okay
and we just get defined some of the
parameters
yes
and
we
define the amount of steps
so here we are um defining the steps and
the rate for our
relaxation labeling algorithm and we
want to
minimize the loss yes in this case we
are using this dice loss
ratio simplicity
and
here also shows why it's important for
this algorithm to be relatively fast
because
in order to
get any hyper parameter tuning yes we
need to execute the whole algorithm
multiple times
here i'm just defining the
100 different
points and they are not executed
not all of them are executed
because this is at least a supposed
but still yes it's multiple multiple
execution of the same algorithm and in
order to found find the best
um
[Music]
the best uh configuration of the hyper
parameters yes so did one more time this
is just to show that we can use
basically any uh julia library to
help ourselves
okay and it's done yes so the best would
be these 16 steps from this range that i
chosen and rate 0.008
it should not change so much
but we can execute it one more time with
this
okay and it needs to just to get through
one more time for all of this
it's
reduced the
negative
yes
all of the lever is covered now
and we have a lot of additional noise
yes
and in this particular case it must
minimize the error yes
important
this this is just because we have chosen
the score with the um
with the metrics it would be a bit
better is because those boxes will be
heavily paralyzed
just to show you uh
what can be the problem and here you can
also the plot of the hyperparameter
okay
but
i just need to restart
and now just for let's say spoiler i
will show you the
on the spleen data set this is the
perform the spin data set
what would be the output of the neural
network okay so now i will get to the
different uh part and i will just
describe you
how one can perform
some simple training on the very simple
neural network to get
get a segmentation output
i just need to
ah okay
in a moment it will load
in the meantime i will
start to describe you the
what needs to be done is so this is also
these are also files that you can find
in the repository
just next to the julian notebook
uh and here first is the
load image
so what needs to be considered yes first
of all of course you need to load
the images like
load the images
as you did
at the very beginning so load the paths
as you did at the very beginning um then
then we need to find the information
which image is the biggest one why this
is important which image is the biggest
because
the neural network expects
the
um the same dimensions of the rs that
would be
put
into its
yes so when we would put
in order to
put the arrow as the argument yes as the
training sample
it needs to have exactly the same
dimension
as all of the other arrays that we put
so we need to get the idea what is the
biggest one but what is also important
we need to get this idea what is the
biggest one after we change the panic
so we need to have the same padding um
in order for the neural network to get
the idea well about the distances yes so
it needs to have the uniform uh
uniformized data the standardized data
with the same padding i had chosen here
uh the the target spacing of the one
half one half one and a half one and a
half and one and a half so basically
there is some research that
isovolumetric boxes of boxes that has uh
freed um
all of these three dimensions the same
works a bit better
whether it should be one one and a half
or two um is the open problem basically
[Music]
and
and here
okay so we just need to get the same
spacing when we change the spacing the
size of the arrow is changing because
yes because you can squeeze it or
enlarge it depending on the case so we
change the spacing yes getting to the uh
spacing that will be uniform this target
spacing then we can change the size
it would be more performant to get
looked on the size from the metadata of
the image but
i will
keep it from the simplicity and to just
to be very explicit what we are looking
at
and then
we are
choosing the maximum
x y and z dimensions yes why we um
yes maximum x y and z dimensions in
order
to pad
the uh the whole image to the required
dimensions
uh we also want it to be divisible by
some numbers
like for 64 for example
because of the unit architecture and i
will show you in a moment in some image
how it works
um
okay and then we are loading the data
so we are loading and padding the data
what is also important
when we are
doing the
interpolation yes so interpolation is
the process when we are changing the
dimensions of the data changing the size
of the data when you are doing the
interpolation we need to do the
interpolation differently for the image
and for the labels yes that's why we
have different
um
different definitions yes so here we
need to pass the true for the label at
the last argument in the first uh to the
left and to the first circle
uh
in this particular case of the spleen
uh we need to also um
when i was looking at the uh at the data
set before the workshop uh
i could also see that the tops and downs
of the
labels were artificially set to one yeah
so there was some error as at least in
my pc uh so i needed to set it to zero
and we save all of this into the hdf5
so after this process um we would have
on the hard disk
the prepared data centers of course this
is extremely simplified uh pre-processed
yes
in case of the mri we need also the
standardization bias suite collection uh
and there is tons of tons of things that
one could do and in in order to get the
best performance should do but we'll get
to the most basic and most essential
things here yes
um also what is important here i did not
parallelize the code and just for
simplicity we can parallelize it yes
there is a
hdf5
parallel format of the hdf5 and of
course in this case we would have the
end fault depending on the number of
course um acceleration
and
this is just for checking
[Music]
here okay so here is the data that is
prepared already
uh
you see there is a lot of padding yes
for this case i chosen the padding zero
it should be basically the padding the
same as the corners yes so
in the state of the art basically one
chooses the median of all of the four
corners and set it as the background
color but here i wanted to for you to
see the body
and here
is the output of the algorithm yes i
will show you which one
[Music]
so this is the outwards of the algorithm
this is a spleen yes and this works
extremely well to see the spleen
so
as you see
is yes it's extremely well
well describing where the spin is
and this is very simple unit very simple
process although it has a lot of
artifacts as you can see yeah so
i do not know exactly why this happens
but i have such artifacts and um
this is some problem of the unit
probably this is the fact that this is a
two-dimensional unit
that is implemented in such a way in
order to reduce the memory consumption
um okay and now but this is let's say a
bit spoiler yes so um
and just one more thing just to show you
this is the
gold standard yes
this is a ghostland that's nearly the
same in case of the lever but of course
without the noise around
in case of the spin sorry so the spin is
nearly
perfectly described by the unit
okay and what is important this is also
the image that was not seen by the
algorithm but however let's jump into
the
uh into the unit implementation itself
um so this is based on the unit
implement this copied basically from the
segmentations models the jl
the library the open source library that
have some implementations of different
algorithms different architectures the
unit that i found there was to my liking
but there are other units also
implementations that are present i will
show you one
later just to describe
how the unit hub works or maybe now
actually
[Music]
this is from the medical model so the 3d
unit the unit
that basically would work better but has
a lot of memory consumption so i did not
want it uh to use it here uh just to
enable everybody to run it even weaker
you use
but how does the unit works yes
basically this is for those that does
not uh know this is how the flux is um
performing the
is constructing the neural networks
uh so we have chain by decomposition uh
chain creating creates basically the
composition of the functions here so we
have l1 then we have chain l1 and chine
this one with uh
l3 is the chain of the l3 l2 and
something else and so on we'll chain
chain chain to the end
uh and convolutions um
is just the way how to look at the
neighborhood here so as we were
describing how a very simplistic
algorithm
for the most of the workshop
i have shown that using the information
around from the area around it can get
us a long way yes maybe not to them
to the best algorithm but still a long
way here is the same yes so basically
the
why the convolutional neural network
source conversion neural network cells
because the convolutions are looking
into the area around and on the base of
the area around
they compress this data
s into the
reduced form let's say
and
and in classic convolutions it's
basically like data so in classic
convolutions in classic classic
segmentations we have this um maybe our
just right here in classic convolutions
we get some array yes
and we use the convolutions that we can
exemplify as these squares
we have for some pullings for example
max pooling
and we reduce the data just to one point
from the neighborhood yes
for example yes there are a lot a lot of
possibilities and we get the small
energy neighborhood because we just
pulled uh the information from the
neighborhood
and then we can get it even smaller
representation that summarizes all of
the information
however in case of the unit
then we have the convolutions yes so we
get one more time bigger
and bigger
yes
as you have seen the code and that will
get back into the moment uh why this is
done this is done in order to be able to
get some skip connections between the
layers
so we need to have this skip connections
will work only if the layers have the
same dimensions
so they need to uh
when we have done some pulling then we
need needed to done some deconvolutions
basically
uh
this uh there is one very historic but
very useful uh definition what is the
unit unit was defined um in some old
book
as the
shape and
texture
neural network so it
why it's shape and texture shape because
when we have this pulling pulling
pulling layers basically we get the idea
the compressed idea about the shapes of
the things that we're interested in but
the information about the texture is
mostly lost
during this pulling operations still in
case of the medical imaging the
information about the textures or about
the neighborhood information basically
is extremely important so in order to
preserve this information we have these
skip connections okay
um this is the basic idea behind it
and you can see this skip connections
here residual connections between 16 and
14 for example yes
here
um
okay
and oh and one more thing and this is
also because of these pullings this is
also why i created this to be divisible
by 64. because uh in my case i created
the four layers yes four pullings
and in order for it to play well it need
to be divisible by 2 by 2 by 2 by 2 yes
so in case of the 64 and
it was very um
useful at least it worked better
okay and now uh
how we train it basically uh we need to
uh get the training case validation case
training case would be all of the case
from 1 to 80 in the case of the spin
data set
then we have the unit in case these four
stages as i told you a moment ago we
pass the unit onto the gpu
define some optimizer parameters from
the model and loss function in this case
the loss function of the dice for just
to be classic let's see
and then
we
in order to make the model as simple as
possible
we divide it into slices yes so i just
get a slice by slice i have defined here
a two two dimensional unit so it can
only work on slices
just to preserve the memory
and
when we are reduced when we are choosing
the slices i'm choosing only the slices
and that are
where is it
i'm not here
i'm only choosing the slices that has
anything positive like here yes so if
the slice only have some spin in it it
will be chosen if that it does not have
any spin inside it will not be chosen
yes so one more time i'm getting this
three dimensional array
i'm choosing slices over it i'm checking
each slice where the it has the
spin in it yes and then those splices
are mixed among all of
the um
mix between all of the
oh sorry i'm tired mix between all of
the
[Music]
images yes and
on this data we will train yes
here we are fusing the slices for all of
the images
and we can divide it into the batches
yes so in case of the batches
it would go better yes so we can get a
train loader and train loader
and pass through another 2k iterator but
uh
i do not want i want to keep it simple
yes so uh it will not be done like this
for in this particular example
so here
in the epoch yes so when we are training
the neural network we are training this
in the number of epochs yes i had chosen
650 epochs so it will take a couple
hours for to train it
but
and
during the training we have this
positive
this layers which i shuffled the layer
it can be also achieved more cleanly
let's say in the training order but
getting the shuffle changing the shuffle
to the truth
um
it's uh
then i'm loading the data onto the gpu
using uh the function from the cuda dot
jl so the query writer it works
extremely well uh in passing the data
onto the gpu
then
this is a classic gpu training cycle for
the flux and then we are
passing d um checking the gradients and
optimizing using those gradients
so
we need
uh
one more time yes we have the neural
network neural networks has some
parameters
in order to for the neural networks to
learn the data we need to pass this data
uh get
uh the gradients in respect to loss
functions
then
using those gradients we can optimize
the parameters and when we will get the
best parameters we will
have the best
hopefully have the best
performance and then we are
saving the model using uh
bs on
to some path in order not to lose the
idea
so let's say we are finished this we've
saved it and then we can load it
and execute it yes so uh
the result of this
is displayed already here because i
saved it into the hdf5
so we loaded image loaded label
uh
divided into slices executed
for each
by the in case in each part by the model
passed the data onto cpu
checked the output
created the group to save it yes and it
was ready to visualize as you see now
okay
do you have any questions for the moment
basically i finished but uh i will also
tell a bit more about what can be done
further
what are the feather directions
basically
but do you have any questions for now
okay i assume that there are no
questions
um
okay
so
uh so what uh what should be done also
in this
in this neural network that i did not
done for the simplicity sake
in order for get a better far better
performance we should uh augment data
okay so how does the augmentation of the
data
works
i want data augmentation
okay here like this data augmentation is
that we get some data and we modify this
artificially in some way yes
so it can be for example
a fine deformation so it would change
the shape we can change intensity inside
we can rotate it
we can uh
slice out some of the parts yes
there are a lot of possible
uh there's a lot of possibilities
oh thank you very much
uh
we there are a lot of possibilities that
we can augment the data yes so we can
augment the data by modifying it by
modifying it to
[Music]
get the
possible
variability
uh that we expect yes so for example in
case of the
lungs yes rotation
when we get just zoom into the very
particular spot the rotations usually
are very good but if we have we are not
zooming in and we are just looking at
the whole lungs for example rotation
would lose some information
this is uh quite a deep topic that needs
an understanding um
however there are a lot a lot of
different augmentations depending on the
case that we are and depending on the
invariances that we want to achieve so
the invariance is one of the most
important thing basically in all of the
deep learning
and what is in variance um in this case
environment is lack of sensitivity to
something
so for example if we have
a person yes
the
algorithm that is recognizing the liver
should be invariant to some extent to
the scale yes so it should recognize
that the liver is liver in a big and a
small person it should be a
invariant to translation yes so whether
we are moving it to some site basically
convolutional network networks are
invariant to translations it should be
environment to some rotation usually
it's not always the case but usually
and some intensity modification because
or
depending on the image increasing
intensity would be in the
in case of the mri density in case of
the ct scan cut
so uh this would be
yes
all of this can change and we know that
it can change because this is logical
yes the liver can move the person is
breathing the person can be bigger
smaller
the person can be obese and when the
person is obese
will have a lot of fat and the intensity
and uh the radiolucency will change
um
okay so what kind of augmentations for
city images yes it's one more time
depends on the particular case but uh
the usually the most important are these
spatial transformations yes so like
translation like in some cases rotation
although in most in many cases i do not
use rotation because rotation can lose
some information basically if you
imagine yes um that something can be
done
that something can change and you can
synthesize the data that will look like
this change data it's good to do yes for
example in case of deliver we know that
we are breathing so translation up and
down
is
common yes it's normal so we would
augment the the data by translation up
and down
we would land the neural networks for
the cases that are normal
liver does not rotate 90 degrees yes so
it's not normal
so if you would add the augmentation
that
rotate deliver 90 degrees
it will the neural network will learn
something that is fiction so it's not
useful basically
at least in principle
but if we would look for example at the
um
[Music]
i don't know
at the
nodule in the
in the lung yes it can look
basically the same whether we rotate
this and or not
in some cases switching the intensity is
important in some cases intensity like i
don't know for example in the
supernatural glands intensity is quite
stable and it's typical for the disease
yeah so shifting the intensity will lose
the information so what augmentations
exactly are good for each case is
depending on the problem yes some
augmentations like translations are
usually the good case usually the
intensity transformations are the good
case but
there is no one solution for all
basically it's problem dependent to big
extent
we want to synthesize the data that is
probable to happen in real life
okay this is the idea
um so this is the first thing that
should be done yes these augmentations
the data should be analyzed in 3d not in
2d
as i did
i would choose some different metric
or at least choose different metrics and
try different metrics out in the uh have
a parameter tuning the hyper parameter
tuning here should be uh performed um by
trying different uh architectures
uh
and so on so and so basically there are
hundreds of possibilities that we we can
do here what is also important
and this is one of the reason uh that i
want to work with julia is that we can
do all of it all of those processes so
augmentations different metrics um
different steps
um
we can make it differentiable and if you
can make it differentiable
we at least in principle can do it as a
one big
optimization problem not as a hyper
parametric tuning problem that is harder
but far more efficient optimization
problem
i am for example now working on the uh
prostate mris
and i'm working to
fuse different architectures here so if
we use for example the super voxel
architecture
with the
neural network the
siamese neural network
with the graph neural network um and all
of them put into work one big chain of
the back propagation um
this is just the work that i started so
i do not i cannot show you the results
uh but this is something that would be
extremely hard to achieve in the other
language
um
[Music]
okay so basically
this is all that i want to uh to cover
for this this we have still 15 minutes
left so
and i just wanted to add one more thing
here so um
i will also hear my email
or maybe not maybe better uh
okay
yes
if you would want to work on something
like with this
uh
you can you can just mail me uh we can
uh i have some
uh access to some data i have a lot of
work to do
and if you would be interested in
uh
writing some
some publication uh getting deeper into
the topic uh we can devise some idea and
we would work on this together if you
want uh also if you would want to get
something
about the tools
i also
try i would try to be as available as
possible you can catch me on the mail
you can catch me on the link
uh or just write the
post on the
some of my repositories
repository this yeah basically
uh repositories are working practice
i would like also to parse the idk to
the pure julia yes so get uh
because it is written in the c plus plus
yes so and simple idk that we are using
here to load the data um could be in
principle get just from the c plus plus
into the
binary boulder
and
those problems that happened today
should be avoided
if all of this would be passed in the
pure julia passing it from the c plus
class uh for the data loading
um also there i would should mention
that in the link
in there is also the set of repositories
that
i'm not an author of
but they are also very useful
by the person
called the black
there are some augment medical
augmentations
yes
some distance transformations calcium
scoring basically i used
these four units and for a lot of other
things they are very useful to look if
you are interested in this topic
and they play well with
my my tools also so you can choose
whatever you want
and
compose whatever you like this is the
strength of the julian
i wanted to keep it like that
uh so thank you very much for listening
to me and uh
i'll be still here and waiting for any
questions um
and any discussion if anybody wants to
discuss something
so thank you very much and
see you
thank you for listening
thank you for participation
okay i hope that
this would be useful for you
thank you
okay i don't think yes you can use it
now with the daikon address
without any problem basically itk
this is this is using the idk yes and uh
simple idk omoni and of course the um
basically the
most uh prevalent uh
way how to handle the data in the
clinical setting is the document uh they
support icon as a whole also what is
important
uh there is a dicom.jl yes so we can
also load
the data into the arrays using the
computer
and
i did not
shown here but
the documentation is also quite nice
so yes
thank you very question
you